you
[Music]
[Applause]
so artificial intelligence is without
doubt the most audacious to need the
most ambitious goal of the field of
computer science it's been with us for
at least 70 years since the time of Alan
Turing it'll probably be another few
decades before we achieve all possible
aspects of artificial intelligence but
right now is a very exciting time for
the field and the thing that's triggered
this excitement of course has been some
very interesting developments in the
field of machine learning so what I
wanted to do in this talk is to offer
some fairly general thoughts about
machine learning and also to share with
you a particular perspective which we'll
call model-based machine learning which
I hope you'll find helpful if you're
trying to apply machine learning in a
practical setting so I think machine
learning is probably a fairly tough
field for newcomers right now there are
literally thousands of different
algorithms the conferences are exploding
that said six six thousand people last
year hundreds and hundreds of papers
being published it's quite bewildering
how do you find your way around this
complex field and in particular if
you're trying to solve a practical
application which of these thousands of
different algorithms and techniques
should you be using indeed why do we
need all these different machine
learning algorithms can't we just have a
single general-purpose algorithm that we
use for all applications well it turns
out that we can't because of a very
important theorem which has this
wonderful name of the no free lunch
theorem I love it what it says is that
if we average over all possible data
distributions then every classification
algorithm has the same error rate as
every other when classifying previously
unobserved data points and so what that
means is there's no such thing as a
universal machine learning algorithm so
the goal of machine learning is not to
find the single machine learning
algorithm
instead the goal is to find a particular
algorithm that's well suited to the
specific problem that you're trying to
solve so I'm going to think about this
is in terms of what they'll call
model-based machine learning so the
difference between one algorithm and
another the difference in an algorithm
that's good for your application and an
algorithm that's not good for your
application concerns the effectively the
assumptions or the constraints that are
built into that algorithm and so the
idea of model-based machine learning is
to be very explicit about this in other
words we're going to not search this
huge space of algorithms or pick ones at
random or ones you're familiar with or
ones you happen to have software
implementations of but instead we're
actually going to derive the appropriate
machine learning algorithm by first of
all making explicit the modeling
assumptions and we'll see how that works
in a moment so the traditional view we
say how do I shoehorn my problems into
some standard algorithm that I happen to
be familiar with or they happen to have
software for that's the traditional view
but in the model-based view we take a
different perspective and we say what is
the appropriate algorithm for my
particular application in other words
what is the model or to attend are they
what are the set of assumptions that are
appropriate for my particular
application so instead of thinking of
the machine learning algorithms the
first class citizen instead we're going
to derive that algorithm we're going to
derive it actually from two things as it
happens the model then the model is the
set of assumptions that we're making in
the context of a particular application
along with an inference method now I
don't have time in this talk to discuss
inference but the there are probably
relatively few different inference
techniques that we might apply they're
fairly generic they might be simple
things like stochastic gradient descent
they might be things like maximum
likelihood or you might have some
sophisticated Bayesian message passing
algorithm but it's when we apply an
inference algorithm to a particular
model that we get a specific machine
learning algorithm so you might be
thinking well hang on a minute what
about the neural networks aren't deep
neural networks or sort of universal
machine learning algorithm they solve
every problem there is I've read
somewhere let's just think about that
for a minute let's just start with a
very simple if you like neural network
logistic regressions and logistic
regression actually had some very strong
assumptions built in it says the output
Y is a linear combination of the
features the things that I measure and
pass through some nonlinear function so
there's a very very tight very narrow
assumptions a neural network is a little
more general it says that the output is
going to be a nonlinear function of a
linear combination of some features and
those features themselves are going to
be derived by taking nonlinearities of
other linear combinations of features so
we end up with a hierarchical structure
and of course the more layers you have
the more money you get paid we learn
from Harry yesterday so even that deep
neural network has a functions the
assumptions are that the outputs are
obtained by these simple linear
combinations of features which
themselves are constructed
hierarchically now it turns out that
that set of assumptions is very valuable
in quite a broad range of applications
but it can't be universal because of the
no free lunch theorem and indeed even
that structure is often not sufficient
we often have even in the context to
deepen your networks further assumptions
so here's a fairly familiar one if we're
looking at image processing we may use a
convolutional network so here there are
much tighter construct constraints now
that a node looks a little patch in the
previous layer and as we scan through
the nodes in that convolutional layer
the weights are actually shared they're
constrained to be equal so we have large
numbers of weights but relatively few
independent parameters are very tight
constraints and then we do some sub
sampling and of course this network may
have certain numbers of layers certain
choices of nodes in the hidden layers
and swords and a lot of assumptions
built in to these seemingly rather
generic techniques
so something else to consider is the
relationship between data and and these
assumptions or these constraints or what
sometimes call prior knowledge so
machine learning is not data plus black
box machine learning is data plus
assumptions we need data and we need the
assumptions otherwise no free lunch
themselves as we can't learn anything we
can't make predictions so let's think
about data and prior knowledge let's
suppose we're trying to detect the
presence of a person in an image well we
know that the presence or absence of a
person in an image doesn't depend upon
where they are in the image and so if we
have a rather naive approach we have
better have a very large data set
showing people at every possible
location in all that we can recognize a
person irrespective of where they are
now much smarter technique is to build
in that assumption of what we call
translation invariance if we bake that
into our model as an explicit assumption
now we only need examples where the
person let's say offended in the image
and now the system will automatically
generalize to any other position so
greatly reducing the amount of data that
we need so we see this relationship
between data and prior knowledge now you
might be thinking at this point well
hang on a minute yes that may all be
very well in the days when datasets were
very small and we need a lot of strong
constraints or a strong prior knowledge
to augment this very sparse data but
we're now in the world of big data we're
in the world of exponentially growing
datasets amount of data in the world is
doubling every maybe 18 months or so
we're drowning in vast quantities of
data so maybe we can forget about all
these strong constraints and we can go
back to some very generic weak model
well one thing to appreciate is that
there are two meanings of the term size
when we talk about data so I'll
distinguish between the computational
size of a data set and the statistical
size and a data set so let me give you
two sort of rather hypothetical corner
cases let's suppose we want to
understand the relationship between
current and voltage when we apply a
voltage to a piece of but metal we
measure the current flowing through it
so we might gather some data points I
guess here we've got seven data points
whose data point is a pair
of real numbers representing the voltage
and the corresponding current and our
goal is let's say to predict the current
at some new value for the voltage well
in the absence of any assumptions it
turns out we can't do that the no free
lunch theorem says we have no way of
predicting the current of that new
voltage if we make no assumptions so
have to make some assumptions in this
case we go and consult our local
friendly physicist who tells us wow this
is this is actually is the one parameter
problem the the relationship is linear
passes through the origin is called
Ohm's law and so we only really have to
discover one parameter which is the
slope of that line so in this context
seven somewhat noisy measurements of
current and voltage really do a great
job of pinning down the value for the
resistance and allowing us to make a
fairly accurate prediction of the
current at that new voltage so it's an
example of a data set we've got seven
pairs of numbers so computationally it's
a tiny data set but statistically it's
very large if I give you another million
pairs of measurements of current and
voltage you can make a slightly more
precise prediction there already was
just seven you're already doing
extremely well so that's a dataset which
is computationally small but
statistically large so think about a
different corner case let's imagine we
have integers and we're trying to
recognize or classify the images
according to the object they contain
aeroplane bicycle and so on the images
might have a million pixels and we might
have millions and millions of these
images the space of possible images is
vast if you just think about a 10 by 10
pixel image and each pixel is either
black or white then the number of
possible settings of those pixels
exceeds the number of atoms in the
universe and that's a tiny image so now
we have these these million pixel images
even on a very big data set it's
extremely sparse in the space of
possible images and so even so this is a
data set which might computationally be
very large it occupies a large amount of
space on the disk but unless we build in
a lot of assumptions we're going to find
it very difficult to make these
classifications we will make a lot of
assumptions about correlation nearby
pixels translation invariant scale
invariants and so on as we baking those
extra assumptions then we can start to
do
good job of classifying the objects in
those images so this would be an example
of a data set which is computationally
large it has lock you PI's lots of
megabytes that statistically it's very
sparse it's a small data set so can we
do something rather generic can we not
only have a perspective on machine
learning this model-based perspective
which says instead of instead of
drowning in this sea of thousands of
different algorithms and not knowing
what to do now we have a compass the
idea that we're going to be explicit
about our modeling assumptions I'm going
to derive the machine learning algorithm
that's a nice perspective on machine
learning can we do more can we actually
operationalize this could we even
construct tools that a lap would allow
us to derive the machine learning
algorithms automatically so there's a
dream can we can we achieve that dream
or to think about this so I want to
introduce another concept so so far I
focused on learning from data so I see
this as a a profound transformation in
the field of computer science we are
shifting from a world in which software
is handcrafted in which developers tell
the computer what to do step by step
it's a very different world in which we
write very different software rewrites
software that allows the computer to be
adaptive to learn and then we train it
using data so to me this is one of the
most profound perhaps even the most
profound transformation in computer
science in the 70 years since Allen
cheering what I want to tell you now is
that there are really two aspects to
this there's a flip side of this a year
to go with the yang as it were and that
is another I think equally profound
transformation in computer science which
is a shift from determinism logic to a
world of where we quantify uncertainty
so instead of thinking of everything as
zeros and ones we're going to think of
things are sort of gray scales between
zero and one why is that why is that
relevant while I'll show you in a minute
the intimate link between uncertainty
and machine learning but when we're in
this data driven world uncertainty is
everywhere we ask questions like what
movie should the user watch now
or what word did the user just write
with their stylus what did the user just
say if we're doing speech recognition
which web page views you're trying to
find if we're doing web search which
which link will the user click on which
gesture is the user making what's the
prognosis for this patient and so on and
so on in this data-driven world it's
very rare that we have certainty and so
we need to embrace uncertainty of the
first-class citizen and think about how
to quantify uncertainty and of course
there is the provably unique consistent
calculus of uncertainty which is I'll
show you all those probability theory so
we just make one comment on probability
which is sort of the generality of
probability so we all learn about
probability in school in a particular
narrow context the frequentist context
we think of probability as the limit of
an infinite number of trials the
probability that an unbiased coin will
land heads means if we take along the
long-run frequency of coin flips will
converge to naught point five because
there's a much more general perspective
on probability which is as a
quantification of uncertainty and maybe
it's a shame that it's called
probability but if you if you try to
ascribe numerical values to uncertainty
and you do so any consistent in a
logical and consistent way it turns out
those numbers are they exactly the same
rules as the numbers which describe the
flips of coins and so we call it
probability but it's a much more general
view of probability probability as a
quantification of uncertainty that's the
beige in perspective so an example would
be a bent coin let's imagine I'm just
making this up and imagine the physics
of this bent coin is actually if you
flip it 60% of the time it will land
concave side up and 40% of cymet land
concave side down but now imagine one
side of this coin is heads and one is
tails and imagine we don't know which is
which if I ask you to make a bet on
whether the coin will land heads or
tails if you're being rational your bet
naught point five because if you bet
anything else I can make money out of
you it doesn't mean that you believe the
frequency of heads will be naught point
five or fifty percent it means you
believe that the frequency of heads will
either be 60 percent or it will be nor
the 40 percent that you don't know which
and so rationally your bets
so if you like the frequency of concave
side up is like the frequencies view of
probability but your uncertainty about
whether it'll land heads or tails has
this Bayesian component because the one
side is either the concave side is
either heads or tails it doesn't change
you just don't know which it is so it's
an expression of ignorance so you may be
thinking well okay so we're going
through a world where everything is 0 or
1 to a world where everything is
described by numbers between 0 & 1 that
doesn't sound like a big deal that
sounds like a tiny change I want to show
you a little example of something which
hopefully will convince you this is
actually quite a radical and different
perspective so here we have a bus and
then we have a car and the bus is longer
than the car ok you follow me so far all
right bicycle and the car is longer than
the bicycle okay so the bus is longer
than the car the car is longer than the
bicycle so hopefully you all agree that
the bus must be longer than the bicycle
okay we call that property transitivity
all right seems sort of complete common
sense obviously true well it turns out
that if you go from the world of
determinism to the world of uncertainty
you can have situations which are
non-transitive and this is so surprising
but again it's not a great way of making
money out of your friends so here's how
you can do it there a thing is called
non-transitive dice so they have an
extraordinary property imagine I take
the yellow diet the top and the blue
down I roll them against each other well
two-thirds of the time blue will produce
a higher number than yellow two-thirds
of the time Green will produce a higher
number than blue two-thirds of the time
red produces a higher number than green
right no great surprises so far but then
amazingly 2/3 of the time yellow
produces a higher number than red and
that's because you can think of each of
these dice as a random number it's
uncertain it has a probability
distribution and the secret is just
simply the choice of numbers so I think
if you look at the blue
yellow there you can see the yellow in
this case actually always throws a three
but two thirds of the time blue will
come up with four one-third the time
they are from zero so blue beats yellow
two thirds of the time but that's true
all the way around this circle in a non
transitive way and if you want to have a
play with these at the end we're going
to hand that sets of non-transitive dice
you can collect these at the end and the
thing is you see if you you can you can
bet against your friends and they can
pick whichever one they like and do the
best of fifteen throws or something
you're almost certain to win and then
when they get fed up and they want your
your dye that's fine you let them have
that one you pick the next one the
series you carry on winning okay by the
time they figure what's going on you'll
have made a lots of money and you can
read a little bit more about how they
work at that about website okay so
that's the world of probability and
uncertainty so what's that got to do
with machine learning why are they worth
at this intimate relationship between
probability and machine learning well
we're going to illustrate that with a
little demonstration and the
demonstration is actually taken from
something that's very much a real-world
example but it's kind of pared down to
its basics for the purpose of this
demonstration and it's the challenge of
recommending films or movies so what we
have is imagine a big matrix there might
be 10,000 columns each column represents
a particular movie and we have users
there might be millions of users so each
row is a user what we have is some data
we've gathered some data about movies
that users like or dislike so we'll have
some entries in this matrix where a
particular user has said they'd like a
particular movie maybe some other
entries where a user has said they
dislike a particular movie but there's
going to be a fairly sparse matrix it's
mostly empty and a sense our goal is to
make predictions for these empty cells
because we want to know whether a user
is going to like or dislike a movie that
they haven't yet seen so if we can just
switch to the to the demonstration so
what we've got here is just a couple of
hundred
fairly well-known movies and the system
has already been trained on ratings for
around 10,000 people but it doesn't know
anything about my preferences I wasn't
part of the training set so what it's
going to do now is learn about my movie
preferences so I'm going to do first of
all is pick one of these movies and I'll
drag it across into the green region and
that means I'm telling the system that
I've watched this movie and I'm giving
it a rating which says I like this movie
ok so what's happening is the the other
movies are being arranged on the screen
in a particular way now the vertical
position is irrelevant they're spread
out vertically just so that you can see
them what matters is the horizontal
position on the screen so if a movie is
tight up against the right-hand edge of
the white region that means the system
is very sure almost certain I'm going to
like that movie if it's tied up against
the left-hand end of the white region
that means it's almost certain that I
will dislike the movie and in the middle
it's 50/50 very unsure what you see at
the moment is that most of the movies
are kind of in the middle you see a lot
of white space down the right and a lot
of white space down the left the
probabilities are all around you know
between sort of point two and point
eight or something like that it's pretty
unsure for most of those movies whether
I like them or not
and that's not surprising because it's
only seen one data point for me that
that one movie that I've rated so what I
need to do is give it a little bit more
data so let's suppose I've watched this
movie and let's say I don't like this
movie so I'll drag that across to the
left hand region what you see now is
machine learning happening before your
very eyes the movies are spreading out
left and right what effectively it's
happening it's comparing my pattern of
likes and dislikes with similar patterns
of likes and dislikes amongst that
population of people who provided
ratings and the the implicit assumption
here the sumption actually that states
into the model is that people who share
my pattern of likes and dislikes for
movies I've rated will share my pattern
of likes and dislikes for ones that I
haven't yet seen and that can be used to
make recommendations and so that's where
these probabilities are fundamentally
are coming from of course it's not
encoded in a set of rules
it's encoded in a public model now I'll
show you the model in a little bit so
that's what it looks like after a couple
of examples let me carry on giving some
rating so let's say here's a movie that
I like again we see spreading out left
and right is that here's a movie let's
say that I don't like and I we see a
very different pattern we see a lot of
white space down the middle most of the
movies are either down the right hand
side what's confident going to like them
or it's down the left hand side and it's
confident that I won't like them there's
one or two in the middle but most of the
white space is now in the middle so
that's if you like the modern view of
machine learning and set of things you
have machine learning as tuning
parameters of a function like some sort
of glorified high dimensional curve
fitting we think of machine learning as
the machine having a model of the world
which is uncertain and expressed through
probabilities and as the machine sees
data it uses the rules of probability to
update those distributions and it
becomes less uncertain it's learning
from the data so if you like to meet the
modern perspective of machine learning I
talked a little bit about the size of
data sets and the difference between the
computational size and the statistical
size another way to think about this is
the difference between data and
information so data is how much space it
takes up on the disk how many ones and
zeros there are on the disk but
information is something different
information the the theory of
information was set up by Claude Shannon
in the 1930s and he defined information
as the degree of surprise and so we can
look at the different information
content of different pieces of data so
let's take let's take one of the movies
down the right hand side this is a movie
where it's very confident but I'm going
to like the movie so let's suppose I
watch the movie and indeed I do like the
movie watch what happens to the other
movies when I let go of the mouse
buttons you watch carefully oh then if
you saw that let's pick another example
so again this is a movie that it's
confident I'm going to like and yes
indeed I do like it so I let go of the
mouse button watch what happens the
other movies here we go okay I guess you
saw that just a tiny update that's
because there's very little surprise in
that data it's expecting me to like the
movie and I do like the movie there's
very little surprise
very little information in that data but
each of these ratings contains the same
amount of data it's a 1 or a 0 so then
added data is the same the amount of
information is very small let's see what
happens if I take a movie where it's
very confident that I'm going to like
the movie but let's suppose that I don't
like the movie so I'll put it over here
so again watch very carefully as I let
go of the mouse button ok so very
different a very different outcome err
there's a much bigger change now and
that's because there's a lot more
information in that same amount of data
in fact the amount of information in the
data varies from zero at one end and
goes logarithmically to infinity as we
go to the other end ok if we go back to
the slides then please ok so that's the
that's the relationship then between
between data and information the
relationship between machine learning
and the quantification of uncertainty
through probabilities so what I want to
do now is to introduce a little bit of
graphical notation some of you will
already be familiar with this and you'll
learn nothing in the next two slides I'm
afraid for those of you who may not have
come across the idea of a factor graph
this is a really quick to slide tutorial
that will show you what the pictorial
representation means and will just allow
you to get something out of the out of
the pictures that I'm going to show
later so let's introduce the idea of a
factor graph and let's just have a very
simple example let's suppose we have a
couple of jars a green jar and a blue
jar and I might pick one of these jars
at random but maybe not with equal
probability maybe I pick the green jar
with 70% probability in the blue jar
with 30% probabilities let's say and we
can describe that with a little piece of
graphical notation so the circle here
represents a random variable and
uncertain variable in this case it's the
variable jar so jar is a variable which
can take the state either green or blue
and it's a random variable its status
described by a governed by a probability
distribution in this case a very simple
distribution 70% 30% and that
probability distribution described out
that little black square that black
square is called a factor and so there's
a little arrow from the factor to the to
the variable showing that that factor
governs the distribution of that
variable
now let's imagine these jars have
cookies imagine there are two kinds of
cookies there are round cookies and
triangular cookies but perhaps are on
equal numbers of these BAPS the the Rand
there are more round cookies in this
case twice as many round cookies as
triangular cookies so if I picked a
cookie out of the jar there be some
probability in this case I guess a
probability 2/3 that I would pick a
round cookie in a probability 1/3 that I
would pick a triangular cookie the blue
jar contains cookies as well perhaps
there's a different proportion of
triangular and round cookie so in this
case there's only a 1/3 probability of
picking a round cookie if I choose one
from the blue jar so the probability of
taking a cookie depends upon which jar
it is so again we have a random variable
the variable is cookie and cookie takes
the value either triangle or circle if
governed by a probability distribution
which is the little factor the square a
little black square but the the value of
that distribution itself depends upon
whether we're talking about the green
jar or the blue jar so there's a line
connecting the variable jar to that
factor okay so that's that we call that
a factor graph it's called a factor
graph because the joint probability
distribution of the variable cookies and
jars just obtained by multiplying those
two things together so it's expressing
the joint distribution as a product of
these factors and we can think of this
as a sort of a generative model that is
to say we can think of this as a as a
process by which we could generate data
so we imagine first of all flipping a
biased coin to decide whether we pick
the green or the blue jar let's say we
pick the green jar then we reach into
the jar we pull out a cookie we observe
whether it's a triangle or circle let me
put it back again and so this is a
top-to-bottom generative process for
picking a jar and then picking value of
cookie conditional upon that jar and
typically though we want to do things in
reverse so generally speaking we in a
practical application
we typically observe some of these leaf
nodes so in this case we might have we
might be told that the cookie is a round
cookie and we want to know did it come
from the green jar or the blue jar now
of course we can't be certain
but we can do is to compute the
probability so we can work backwards in
this case are just a little application
of the summon product rule of
probability of Bayes theorem if you like
which would allow us to revise the
probability of it being the green or the
blue jar and to convert that initial
prior probability into into what we call
a posterior probability so this is a
sort of lightening to slide introduction
to the idea of a factor graph and we can
think of these elements as like LEGO
building blocks out of which we can
construct models and those models can
capture in an explicit way the
assumptions the prior knowledge that
we're baking in to our machine learning
application and so this gives us a
mechanism to be very explicit about our
assumptions remember machine learning is
data plus assumptions this allows us to
make our assumptions very explicit so
let's consider a simple example then
that illustrates the difference between
the traditional view of machine learning
in the model-based view I've chosen one
of the simplest you can call a machine
learning algorithm if you like or a
statistical algorithm it's PCA principal
components analysis so very widely used
and we can think of PCA as an algorithm
a recipe if you like it says take the
data so imagine there are capital n data
points you subscribed by these vectors
little X sub n it says first of all take
all your data points in average and so
think of this as a cloud of points in
some high dimensional let's say some
three-dimensional Euclidean space triode
of data points first we'll find the mean
of the data points then subtract off the
mean from each of the data points and
compute this sample covariance matrix
and then compute the eigenvalue
eigenvector spectrum of that covariance
matrix and then retain a subset of the
eigenvectors n which is less than D so D
is the dimensionality of this space that
sets three dimensional will retain m
eigenvectors that say two corresponding
to the m largest eigenvalues so we can
think of this as a way of if you like
compressing the data from three
dimensions down to a two dimensional
linear space oriented in some way in
that three dimensional space so it's a
recipe it's an algorithm where the heck
did that come from
why do that who knows okay let's take a
model-based approach which is much more
enlightening so let's think about a
generative model of data so first of all
we're going to sample a data point Z in
some M dimensional some low dimensional
space from some gas in distribution so
think of a two dimensional space draw a
data point from the Gaussian
distribution
then let's project that into our three
dimensional space so it's now a point in
3d space and imagine a Gaussian adding
some Gaussian noise the Gaussian blob
around that point in sample from that
and that's our data point X okay so
that's a little generative process for
getting a data point so I'm probably
gassing the low dimensional space
projection high dimensional space and
add some Gaussian noise when I do that n
times and his little piece of notation
is called a plate it just says take
everything inside that box and replicate
it n times it's just a shorthand set of
having to write it out lots of times
that's called a plate I want that saying
is that the data points we're going to
assume they're generated independently
to repeat this process n times with a
cloud of endpoints so that's our
generative process so that's our model
that's the sets and set of assumptions
that we're going to make about our data
now what we're going to do is come along
with the actual observed data so I'm
going to take the model and then combine
it with the data so the node at the
bottom or in this case in n nodes
because it's replicated end times are
shaded meaning those they're now
observed rather like observing that the
cookie is round when I observing the
values of those n data points that's our
observed data and now we need to do the
apply Bayes theorem and work in Reverse
to update and the find posterior
distributions for those dead points in
that low dimensional latent space what I
haven't shown explicitly although could
have didn't made the diagram a little
bit more complex the parameters
governing the mean of the data and the
orientation of that plane that
two-dimensional plane in
three-dimensional space and we can infer
those as well as part of that inference
algorithm and it turns out guess what
it's identical to principal components
analysis so if you do maximum likelihood
inference on the model exactly as I
described the maximum
good solution is exactly principal
component analysis the difference though
is we've derived pca by making some very
explicit assumptions and as well as sort
of shedding light on the nature of pca
the more important thing is that if
those are not quite the right
assumptions if we make some different
assumptions we'll arrive at a slightly
different algorithm but one that's more
appropriate to the problem we're trying
to solve moreover you didn't need to
know that this was called PCA okay you
just write down your assumptions derive
the machine learning algorithm and it
does the right thing so let's suppose
that that assumption some of those
assumptions are not correct let's
suppose the assumption of these data
points being independent is not correct
let's move the devlins are not
independent they actually come from a
time series and adjacent points in the
time series are correlated so here's a
case where we have here our first data
point at time step one we have some
latent variable mu Gaussian and it's
generating that it's emitting this
Gaussian observe Gaussian noise
corrupted observation X but at the next
time step the latent state is not drawn
independently from the Gaussian but it's
drawn in from a Gaussian this condition
on the previous state so think of that
as taking the previous state and adding
a little bit of Gaussian noise so a
concrete example imagine we're air
traffic control we're trying to track an
aeroplane as it flies across the sky
we've got a radar and once a second the
radar sends out a pulse it bounces off
the aeroplane it comes back and we
measure the position of the aeroplane
now our radar isn't perfect the
measurement is noisy but also the
aeroplane isn't stationary there are
planes moving okay so there are planes
moving across the sky and we keep
measuring its position so got a problem
the problem is that every time you make
a measurement the measurement is noisy
and the other problems the airplanes
moving that the airplane was stationary
we kept measuring it we could take all
those measurements and average them and
the the random noise would sort of
average out a lot more and more
measurements would become more and more
sure about where the aeroplane was but
there our plane is moving so what should
we do or we could just take the latest
position the latest measurement that
would that would get rid of the movement
effect that the numbers removed
the measurements are noisy that Songhai
doesn't seem right because they're
throwing away measures that we've
already made that feel as if they could
be useful
your intuition says maybe you should
somehow average the data points that
give more weight to the recent
measurements and less weight to more
distant measurements when the airplane
was some way off so you could code up
some sort of ad-hoc thing like that but
instead let's write down the model so
here's the model and then we'll do
inference the right thing will happen so
this says that the aeroplane was at
position mu at time step 1
and we made a noisy measurement of its
position X then it moves a little bit to
some new position at time step 2 and we
made another noisy measurement and then
it moved to position 3 and so on okay so
that's our model and now we're going to
observe the measurements the things
shown in blue and we want to update the
distributions for the the latent
variables which are the actual position
of the unknown position of the airplane
mode so where was the aeroplane at each
time step and a particular at the most
recent time step and if you run maximum
likelihood on that model instead of
getting PCA you get something else now
there's something else happens to be
called the Kalman filter a few years ago
I was writing a book on machine learning
and I had a chapter on time series and I
knew I want to talk about Kalman filters
so I got a hold of some books called
introduction to Kalman filters the
Kalman filter and so on I found these
books pretty impenetrable you know Paige
in a chapter after Chapter after Chapter
two finally got to the Kalman filtering
equations big complicated messy
equations a couple couple of chapters
later you get to the Kalman smoothing
equations and it was very complex and I
found it quite hard work to understand
gives a really simple way to understand
the Kalman filter make those assumptions
run maximum likelihood and what you'll
get are the Kalman equations if you just
asked for the latest position that's the
Kalman filtering equations we're going
forwards in time but if you want to use
the newest measurements to work out
where the airplane was a two time steps
earlier you have to go in the other
direction as well and that's the Kalman
smoothing equations the great thing is
you didn't need to know the literature
or read these books about Kalman filters
you just write down the assumptions run
inference and the right thing happens
and by the way if you if instead of
having Gaussian
it states you have discrete hidden
states it turns out maximum likelihood
is now the hidden Markov model again
instead of having the filtering and
smoothing equations you have the forward
and backward equations of the hidden
Markov model derived quite independently
discussed in a completely different
literature using different notation
again hard work to figure out what's
going on with Kalman with the hidden
Markov models but really you don't need
to know you just write down your
assumptions run inference and right
things happen so what I've shown you so
far is if you like your perspective on
machine learning a sort of compass to
guide you through this complex world of
thousands of different algorithms can we
do more rather than just give you a way
to construct in principle to construct
the machine learning algorithm could
they actually have a tool that allow it
to happen automatically and so that's
the goal of this particular project
something that Eric actually mentioned
in the introduction so let's think of it
like this we'll talk about the inference
code the code the inference code is the
machine learning algorithm it's the
stuff you get when you have the modeling
assumptions you combine it with the data
and you run inference that computational
process the actual computation grunt of
doing the machine learning that's the
inference code that's usually pretty
complicated I said if you look at the
Kalman filtering and smoothing equations
you know they're big long complicated
messy chunks of linear algebra right all
that has to be coded up so you first of
all have to derive all those all that
mathematics of error-prone
time-consuming then you have to code it
up long complicated bits of code that's
sort of error-prone and time-consuming
but that's your source code then of
course it gets compiled with a regular
compiler down to machine code combined
with the data you run it on your big
processor and outcome predictions of
course with uncertainty because
everything's probabilistic can we
automate that process well it turns out
that we we can and we can start from
something else which is we call this a
probabilistic program so the politic
program is a very short piece of
software which really just corresponds
to that factor graph it just describes
the modeling assumptions so given the
modeling assumptions together with a
choice of inference algorithm we can
automatically generate the inference
code
as it turns out that Public Programs a
little more general than factor graphs
so you can think of public programs as a
generalization of the idea of a program
but augmented with probabilities as
first-class citizens and so this is the
dream of a project called Infonet it's
been running for maybe 12 years or more
now in the cambridge lab we haven't
really got to the promised land in fur
that doesn't do everything yes it can't
handle all models and all inference
algorithms but it's already very
flexible very powerful one of the
interesting things about internet it's
not the only product programming
language or environment there are
actually dozens of them what's
interesting about instead of net is that
whereas some of these other public
programming languages and environments
are aimed at generality and they tend to
use techniques based on Markov chain
Monte Carlo methods which are very
general and very flexible the
conversation tend to be very slow and
inefficient incident net uses a so
called message passing techniques things
like expectation propagation and
variable message passing which are
approximate inference algorithms but
they're very efficient and they scale so
for instance we used in philip net a
year or so ago to build a triage system
for exchange so this takes your email
there's not to do a junk this is do with
taking your email and sifting it into
high-priority stuff that you want to see
now and then low priority stuff that you
can sort of deal with on a Friday
afternoon and furthermore to have a
system which just like the movie
recommender as you interact with your
email and you delete and read stuff and
file stuff it learns a personalized
model so it starts off with a general
model that's sort of decent but then it
personalizes it learns what for you is
important high-priority email and what
is less important can be can be treated
as clutter and so that's applied to
Microsoft's email system on exchange
obviously a very large scale application
of Bayesian inference and so if anybody
suggests that these methods don't scale
there's a fantastic counter example and
we've used this in other contexts as
well the movie recommender example I
showed you was just a little toy demo
but the code running on there again is
based on infant net and you use these at
NEADS of that code to build the
recommendation engine which runs on the
xbox live recommending things up movies
and games okay so that's some info net I
thought I'd just show you the factor
graph for the movie recommender so you
see a lot of variables here encoding a
lot of structure a lot of knowledge this
is this is where the assumptions about
the relationship between in this case
user features because in a real
application of in a real movie
recommender application you often know
something about the user you may know
something about their geography or their
age or their gender which might
influence their preferences likewise
with the items the movies you may know
the whether it's a romantic comedy or an
action-adventure you may know the
director some of the actors the length
of the movie and so on those might all
be relevance you combine that with the
ratings from other people that's the
collaborative filtering aspect and all
of them get combined together in this
glorious graphical model so that's the
model the thing we observe the rating so
we observe and obviously the huge
numbers of potential rating that's a
very few of them are observed and with
then we're running inference to update
the probability distributions for all
these random variables in this graphical
model and then propagating down to
update the probability distributions for
ratings that we've not yet observed and
that those give us revised probabilities
for movies that the user has not yet
seen that that was what's happening on
the screen when the movies are moving
left and right those probabilities were
being updated by this message passing
inference process again poor build using
in philip net so it's going to finish
then with a example another example of
the application of this viewpoint and
it's an application in the domain of
healthcare now chosen healthcare for a
couple of reasons the first one is I'm
personally very passionate about this
had a very interesting panel discussion
just now and I think one of the points
was made about the while there are you
know many challenges and potential
pitfalls in the use of machine learning
and AI also the world as it exists today
is far from perfect and that's certainly
true in the world of healthcare there's
a tremendous opportunity to apply
machine learning
techniques to make dramatic improvements
in in healthcare and so this is an
application area that I'm personally
very excited about but it's also an area
where although we have a lot of data and
potentially we could have a great deal
of data in the future there's also a
sense in which we're not to live a
little personalized healthcare we may be
in a world in many healthcare
applications in which the quality the
computational quantity of data may be
very large but the statistical quantity
may be very small so you have huge
amounts of data but I want to live a
personalized healthcare to you with your
particular genotype and your particular
environments in your particular history
and so on we may be in a relatively data
sparse world in which is very important
to be explicit about the assumptions
we're making to extract best value from
that data so the example I'm going to
look at concerns childhood asthma so in
the UK around 5% of the population
suffer from asthma worldwide asthma
cancer 1/4 a million deaths a year so
it's a pretty serious disease and we
know that allergies
represent a major risk factor for asthma
but the relationship between allergies
and asthma is is remains poorly
understood and so we want to see whether
we could apply some of these machine
learning techniques to gain better
understanding the relationship between
allergies and asthma so this is work
that's been done in collaboration with
colleagues at the University of
Cambridge in collaboration with academic
and clinicians academics and clinicians
at the University of Manchester so this
is based on the unmask the Manchester
aspirin and Allergy study it's a birth
cohort study just over thousand children
were registered prenatally back in 1995
and they've been followed through their
lives with this very rich longitudinal
data the children come in at ages 1 3 5
8 11 and so on for a whole series of
tests and we have some some very rich
data this gives you an indication of the
data around 2000 variables many of these
collected at various stages there's
those regular intervals including
genetic information so very rich
longitudinal data set now this diagram
is something that we constructed in the
early stages of the project and they've
captured a qualitative
I level the prior knowledge this is
obtained from the clinician this is
obtained from the experts in astron a
lagina are able to tell us one of the
important factors and variables that we
should consider what are the
relationship between them so this is not
yet a probabilistic factor graph this is
simply a qualitative diagram showing us
the key variables and which ones are
influenced by which others so you can
think of this as the starting point so
being explicit about dysfunctions that
we're going to go into our model which
will then be used to construct the
machine learning algorithm and for the
purpose of this talk I'm just going to
focus on this corner of the diagram
which is the relationship between the
acquisition of sensitization and the way
we can measure that through a couple of
tests one is a skin prick allergy test
and the other is mentioned measuring
Elgin specific immunoglobulin E in
measured from blood tests so here is our
model in some detail you probably can't
read the font it doesn't matter the
details don't matter too much I'll just
sketch this for you the outer plate
represents the children so everything
that fall inside the outer dark box is
replicated just over a thousand times
once for child the inner box represents
the allergens we've got eight allergens
here things that might cat dog pollen
egg and so on and so there's a variable
for each child for each allergen and in
this case for each age so those boxes
represent ages one three five and eight
and each of those variables is a binary
variable saying whether or not that
particular child is allergic to that
particular allergen at that particular
age and now we're making a Markov
assumption we're assuming that whether
the child is allergic at age five is
independent on whether they were
allergic at age one conditioned on
knowing whether they're allergic at age
three so in other words as we go from
one to three to five to eight they
either retain their current state of
sensitization or not sensitization or
they switch now we have some
measurements we can't actually observe
their allergic sensitization what we can
observe though are the results of the
skin prick test and the results of these
blood tests and those are noisy
measurements and so the relationship
between the observation and the hidden
variable is described by
probability that probability describes
the noise in the measurement process we
don't know what those probabilities are
so those themselves are described by
random variables which have
distributions and we're going to infer
those as part of the algorithm likewise
these so-called transition probabilities
the probability that child who is not
emerging at age 3 to pollen will become
allergic at age 5 to pollen there's some
probability of that transition we don't
know what it is so again the value of
that transition probability is itself a
random variable described by
distribution we're going to infer that
distribution and then finally the top
variable is a variable per child and
that's a class and the reason that
variable is there is because we're
testing a hypothesis the hypothesis is
presented to us by the clinicians they
suspected that the relationship between
allergies and asthma had to do not with
whether the child hadn't had a
particular set of allergies or not but
the actual temporal trajectory by which
they had acquired those allergens
through through childhood and so the
idea was to see whether we could detect
natural groupings of children according
to different trajectories of allergic
sensitization again this is built using
Infonet so having described this as a
graph we represent that as a probe list
ik program a relatively compact program
it in for.net and then the internet
compiler automatically generates the
much more complex inference code which
we then execute together with the
observed data in order to make our
inferences one thing we can test is how
many such classes are there how what is
the natural number of groups of children
according to these trajectories of
sensitization and the answer is 4 and
you see them here the top trajectory the
top one so what you're seeing here
different colors represent the the
different ages so age 8 is yellow and
age 1 is in blue and and for the
different allergens cat dog pollen and
so on have you seen these for natural
groups of children so the top group is
quite a big one 600 children in class 0
and they really are not allergic to
anything they're the lucky ones at the
bottom one class 3
they're just allergic to might the class
you don't want to be in is class two
which is the last but one
these are children which are allergic to
multiple different allergens but also
they're allergic early in life if you
look at the class above class one two
hundred children that class they also
allergic to multiple allergens but they
acquire that sensitization later in life
so we call that multiple late but the
multiple early class the one with all
the color their children who have early
sensitization to multiple different
collisions okay so that's what we
discover just by looking at the data
looking at some allergic sensitization
what's that got to do with asthma so the
standard predictor for asthma is called
a poppy is the child does the child have
one or more and sensitization to to some
allergen so if we run our model for a
simple binary to if we force it just to
have two groups then we end up with
these two classes class zero and class
one and we see that twenty percent of
the children in class one have asthma so
asthma is a label that's provided by the
primary care physician the the general
practitioner it was not used in training
and we see that being in class one
there's some significant predictor for
having asthma but if you look at the
natural groupings of children we see a
very different picture we see that if
you're in that multiple early class then
the problem is having a s'more than more
nearly doubled it's now forty percent
and so there's a strong association
between that particular temporal
trajectory of allergic sensitization and
the propensity to have asthma so finally
if you'd like to learn more about the
model based view of machine learning
guess what there's a book coming out
this is an interactive online book it's
freely available it's available now as
in early access form the book is not
finished it's maybe two-thirds complete
but you can go to that URL and look at
the information that's there if you do
go to that URL and look at the book we
just ask for one thing in return which
is that you provide us with feedback
it's a small price to pay for a lot of
work that's gone into this book so just
send your feedback to that email address
several publishers have asked us if we
could wouldn't mind chopping down some
trees and producing a sort of a hardback
copy of this book and surprisingly that
these things still exist we have agreed
that there will be a physical copy of
the book we negotiated very hard for the
highest royalty rates that we could and
I'm pleased to tell you that some all of
the royalties from the physical copy of
the book will go to the Cystic Fibrosis
trust and they'll be matched
dollar-for-dollar
by Microsoft so please buy the physical
book and then go read the interactive
online version because that actually has
a lot more features and details ok thank
you very much Chadwick fabulous oh I
love the phone
[Music]
you